I want to take you inside and I want to
take you inside we're not gonna walk in
as we usually do from the front but
rather I'm gonna take you straight to
the back which is what we're looking at
here in this particular image because
it's an extraordinary ambulatory
remember that's the that's the pathway
around the East End around where the
altar is you can walk behind the altar
and like sue jairs at San Denis it is a
double ambulatory it is very wide by the
way I got to tell you one of the most
annoying things about notre Dom in Paris
is the fact that when you go in and of
course it's always crowded because well
it's in Paris there are so many bright
bulbs and chandeliers I use the term
loosely bunches the light bulbs together
it's hard not to be caught in glares
it's hard to look at something without
having to shade an eye or two but we're
gonna do the best we can given the
possibilities for photographing here but
here we can see something of this very
broad ambulatory here we see it from
another angle where we can see that
there is this row of columns such as we
saw at San Denis by the way unlike San
Denis the nave too has double aisles so
the whole building is extraordinarily
wide and we'll see that aisle a little
bit later on I want to show you this
image because we're standing in the
ambulatory looking through one of the
arches and then looking up into the
vault of the choir so it reminds us that
as we move around the Cathedral we need
to move a lot we need to look at a lot
of different angles because you'll find
some extraordinarily beautiful
combinations of things close up and far
away low vaulting high vaulting lighting
in different times of the day in
different ways sometimes lighting with
color because there'll be stained-glass
windows where the light will be shining
through and casting color onto the stone
so I'm going to say this no doubt many
times but cathedrals need to be visited
carefully looked at in a lot of
different angles both outside and inside
and they need to be visited more than
once because of course the light coming
from the outside comes from different
places at different times of the day and
in different times of the year
now let's look at the interior of Notre
Dom again with all those glaring lights
it's an enormous leap tall Cathedral and
it is extraordinarily long longer and
taller than any we have seen so far and
again it was all built in one we call it
building campaign so there's a kind of
unity to the architecture despite again
all the changes that have taken place
over time if we look here we can see
that double aisle you can see the row of
columns that separates the two aisles so
again an extraordinarily spacious and
beautiful building here is a vault you
can see in the same six part vault that
we've seen in other cathedrals that we
saw in sauce for example but you'll
notice the way the pillars reach up to
support that vault
very different here at Notre Dom than
say at sauce I want to take you back
simply to look once again at the nave
and then I want you to look at the
elevation we have here the aisle and
again it's a double aisle then we have a
gallery and then as you can see we have
an upper part and there are windows in
that upper part called cluster II
windows now we're going to see they're
going to get bigger over time as
cathedrals develop but we need to
recognize this beautiful elevation here
you can see that gallery and it's a very
big gallery there are windows inside the
gallery and then the cluster II windows
up above it now very often when we're
walking around we don't focus on those
kinds of architectural details but it is
important to look and again you can see
with all the angularity of the of the
piers that rise up of the various arches
you've got one arch then three arches
then you've got the window up above one
wants to look at all those proportions
for example and here we take a look at
an interesting situation because those
cluster II windows which you see in the
far left of this photograph are not
original
in fact originally the cluster
contained a round window in part of it
you see that in the corner there we're
looking in the transept here and then up
above it was more wall so it was a lot
darker now what happened they discovered
in restoring the church that these
clerks three windows had replaced the
original arrangement when doing some
some work and so they decided to restore
a couple of these so that you can see
what had have been what it would have
been like except for the fact that more
light comes in today from the original
design than would have come in in the
12th century here again you can see it
so that in the left we have a recreation
of the original although again that
little window would have been wall and
then we see the clerestory windows so
what we have here is partly a
restoration of the original and partly a
13th century fixing if you will or
repair or remodeling of the cathedral
here we look up at the vault and as you
can see again it's that six part ball
you can see those clerks three windows
those 13th century windows going with
the 12th century vault but it really is
quite an impressive structure now what I
want you to notice is that we're going
to look at the piers that hold all this
up and if you look up from this pier you
can see that it goes through a column
and then it goes on up and in fact the
the piece that runs straight up and
makes the transverse arch divides these
vaults in other words this is a
separation of two six part vaults
compare that with this column next to it
which goes up to the rib that is in the
middle of one of those six part
transverse arch vaults you see remember
in sauce you had a wrote a rotation an
alternation of pillars and that double
column here we have gotten rid of that
alternation and all these great columnar
piers and pillars are the same they end
up doing different things because there
are major and minor ones because you've
got the six part fault but they all look
alike
and so notice that when we looked at the
interior how much your eyes were LED all
the way to the altar because there was
nothing sort of alternating there was
nothing breaking that rhythm to lead
your eyes that way so this is a
conscious change in what had been built
just really a couple decades before at
the Cathedral of songs now the transepts
are also not original transept were
added in the 13th century and they're
quite narrow transepts I might add
because the church is so wide the
transept when they were built don't
stick out very far and so once again
it's a kind of peculiarities of Notre
Dom although it's not unique to Notre
Dom and here again we're looking at a
corner where we have the nave to the
left and then one of the transepts to
the right so we can get an idea of how
deep that transept is and the answer is
not very the transepts also not very
wide because it doesn't have any aisles
even though of course there are two
aisles on each side of the nave so like
every Cathedral we're going to look at
there are a lot of differences even in
the original plan let alone all the
remodeling there is no cookie cutter
Cathedral and even though I think we can
make the argument that beginning really
was sharp there's a kind of formula that
tends to be more faithfully reproduced
in other Cathedral as opposed to Notre
Dom and law which we'll look at in the
next lecture and sauce and Sally and Roy
on that we've already looked at in this
sort of experimental phase these are
perhaps more different from each other
but nevertheless they'll never be a
standard cookie cutter here's the plan
here's the prefab Gothic cathedral
that's why it's always worth visiting a
lot and you can never say scene 1 or
scene 10 for that matter and you see
them all the windows in the transept are
in fact a little bit later than the
transept themselves they come from later
in the 13th century and they're too
beautiful rose windows and we can see
here the pattern of
one of them the large circle with the
lengths of windows underneath and each
of the two transepts has in fact these
windows this is the North Rose window
and it contains in the center the image
of the Virgin and Child something very
common to North Rose windows as we will
see in other places and here is the
South Rose and it contains Christ
because we associate the south transept
with the life of Christ and the coming
again of Christ because it receives more
illumination being on the south than
does the North porch we'll see how that
works itself out in more detail
especially when we look at Chartres
Cathedral